he wants to put a check on the dude with
the thin neck a ban on Adam Schiff while
a pundit swings and whiffs Matt Gates
has introduced the pencil resolution
to Bar congressman and look I knew that
would get it and U.S Senate candidate
Adam Schiff from accessing classified
information pencil stands for preventing
extreme negligence with classified
information licenses
oh yeah
the resolution aims to Bar shift from
getting his hands on classified docks
and calls for a house ethics
investigation into him stemming from his
role in the Trump Russia collusion hoax
a theory with bigger holes in it than
Hunters Biden septum
thank you
but of course pencil also cleverly
refers to ships skinny neck
can I make skinny neck jokes cat I don't
know if I can physician heal thyself I
haven't seen a troll that good since
stelter left CNN
speaking of trolls Washington Post
columnist Jennifer Rubin
she recently wrote an op-ed slamming
America's governor Ron DeSantis calling
him a full-blown white supremacist
Banning the college board's advanced
placement for African-American studies
course from Florida schools wait they're
already calling Ron DeSantis a white
supremacist I didn't see that coming
until at least May
she's referring to the sunshine State's
education department rejection of the
advanced placement African-American
studies class due to its focus on black
queer studies then again if I worked for
the Washington Post I wouldn't like
reading either
many consider DeSantis a front runner in
the 2024 presidential election so we
want to get Joe's take on it
hey yeah yeah I hope these guys get
together and get things done work
together across the uh I like them all
um I don't really like those Florida
guys too much
I like uh Chef California
yeah I'm from California no I'm uh
I'm from uh I know where I'm from
I'm aware I'm Delaware I got it that's
how I remember it
he does
let him have an ice cream
cat you told me in the Green Room that
you wish you married Adam Schiff instead
of your husband
you told me that too actually to be fair
what do you think of this here the what
do you first of all what do you think of
Gates's uh clever little uh thing and
will it pass
it's clever clever little thing yeah I I
I think I mean obviously it's a TR it is
a trolling thing right it's it's to get
attention and people talk about it so in
that sense it it absolutely did work but
also yeah Adam Schiff it's that but
that's that's government right it's like
you can be really bad at something over
and over and over again and still keep
your job and only in the government can
you kind of do that so uh I I mean
there's many reasons why what he
shouldn't have access to classified
information but also everybody
apparently just has classified
information hanging out in their house
there's also I think a problem with over
classification of documents so basically
I just take the uplifting view that it's
just all so hopeless
that's the best way to go I think cat
Degen the shift is I mean we make fun of
shift on the show all the time it's hard
for people to take him seriously but
when you talk to Democrats especially
kind of left-wing Democrats from
California they really like the guy
because he was endlessly on Donald Trump
and Donald Trump makes them crazy so
what do you think of his few he's he's
running for the Senate now uh do you
think that Schiff is maybe not as silly
as we think he is in terms of democratic
politics oh no he's irretrievably stupid
too because he was using Chinese spyware
which has been banned on government
devices just a few weeks ago to bemoan
getting kicked off an intelligence
Community uh
proving to the American people that he
should be kicked off the intelligence
Community because he doesn't know he's
using Chinese spyware that's been banned
on government devices I digress I love
the pencil insult though
not just for him but just in general
Pencil Neck
no man likes being called pencil skinny
like every dude would want to have a
little bit of Peck a little bit of
biceps something yeah they don't want to
be that thin and also it's just not yeah
look like a pencil and you smell like
one too because the Eraser is kind of
funky smelling like just the idea of
like what does a pencil eraser smell
like and then pencil shavings put a
pencil shaving smell like vauban you
remember voban it's the powder that they
use in schools to clean up vomit oh my
God I remember that stuff gentle shaving
smell like bow band how weird is it that
in school people are just vomiting all
the time
somebody is ready with some vauban to
just it's like sawdust right yeah can
you blame the boban if someone threw up
here at work just even one time we talk
about it forever but in school it's like
ah again it did happen a lot again you
call somebody you know a pencil I get
from here on out mark my words you're
gonna think about vauban yeah so true
Jason the uh I think that Matt Gates
might have been I don't want to you know
I give credit where credit is due but
maybe he was on the phone with somebody
who gave him that idea for the pencil
legislation what do you think do you
know who I'm talking about Jason maybe
maybe he has a good friend somewhere
yeah the pencil thing's an easy one on
this guy but I gotta tell you well I'm
thinking about that time at the Franklin
Institute that I puked on the floor
right now but Hawaiian ponds warm day
that's why you go to the friends right
makes me want to puke like not many
people make my skin crawl yeah how did
we elect these people and Gates has his
own problems I'm not going to get it
you've never been to Washington have you
no and I will no I have been to
Washington but I wouldn't get near these
people I mean how do we elect such
weirdos
porn stepdad right I took the suit off
you got to get away from that one but
Jillian in a political sense he's
running for Senate now uh he wants to be
the senator from California he is a
congressman right now correct do you
think uh you know I think he has a good
shot because I do think that the left
kind of likes this guy first of all I
don't know if we can get through this
segment without at least mentioning that
Matt Gates has some issues to work out
of course here so let's just start with
that however I will also say
his whole rationale for not wanting
shift to serve on the Intel committee is
that he says Schiff got it dead wrong
right with the Trump yeah Russia
collusion narrative fine but if the bar
for seating members of Congress on
committees was that they could never
have been dead wrong about something we
would literally have no committees in
Washington so it's a little bit of a
slippery slope to get down I almost from
a political standpoint I would think you
know if I were McCarthy I would let
these guys including swalwell on these
committees because you always see these
hearings and because they were in the
minority they didn't have a chance to
challenge these guys but now that
they're running the Committees go ahead
you know let Adam Schiff get up there
and then when he says oh Russia
collusion you can say you've got to give
me the goods now because we're running
the committee what do you think of that
cat no I mean I think you can try but I
think he had think about how long of a
time he spent being able to talk about
it when he also really had nothing yeah
know that it would be that simple or go
that way yeah well it's not the talking
it was the stupend of a Chinese spy that
was the problem yeah that's usually that
usually does you in when you're
isn't it like sticking it in a spot I
get it I get it Dagan hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else